did you ever get uh
told off in school for stuff you did
outside of school
uh uh like as in like in the school
grounds or outside outside of school
like what so
like
the area where i went to school was like
really small yeah and like i was i was
like i don't know how old i was must be
like 13 14. yeah i was like there was
like a bunch of like ruined castles
where i grew up
and one time i was like climbing the
wall of this castle yeah and a teacher
happened to be walking in that park
right and she just saw me she didn't say
anything but i was just climbing it i
wasn't having a great time probably
wasn't the safest thing yeah um it was
quite high up and then i came into
school the next monday because it wasn't
like a weekend i got bollocked by the
[ __ ] teachers they told me off and i
was like i was so confused i was like
this doesn't
it's allowed it was out of school what
and they were telling me off for
climbing this wall outside of school not
even anywhere near school
i don't think i was like
yeah i don't think we had anything like
that because like because because the
the town that i grew up in was like it
was it was small but it was also quite
wide yeah so like uh yeah i don't think
i ever saw my teachers outside of school
yeah i mean i i was in like hove in
brighton so i mean that's that's like a
city so yeah i don't think people cared
about did you guys have like did your
schools have any rivalries with like
other schools we were attached to
another school yeah we had like a sister
school as well so like i was the school
i went to was the boys school and then
like at the bottom of the hill there was
the the girls school
school we were like physically our
schools were physically attacked oh oh
no
but they were different schools yeah so
you could walk into the other school
from school that just sounds like a bad
time
that just sounds like fights yeah were
there a lot of fights that happened it
was like the corridor like where like
the walls were like different colors
like there was a weird line
right so that's where like if [ __ ] went
down it was always like at this like it
was like the the dmz in like north korea
it was like
oh my god standing on the board
it was like [ __ ] went down so the reason
why this this weird like it sounds
really bizarre right yeah yeah so we
were a while speaking school and we were
really small and when we were attached
she was a massive english speaking
really [ __ ] big english speaking yeah
because our school was too small and
like poor to have our own like sports
facilities right so that that school
also had this massive uh sports like
kind of complex attached to it swimming
pool
tennis like massive sports halls astro
turf massive fields tennis courts
everything right yeah they had
everything like rugby pitches
literally everything
um and so
our school would basically share the
facilities with them right so whenever
we needed to go to use the
pool or anything we always walked
through this school right yeah went
there so we could walk through their
school but they couldn't walk through
our school
because our schools are on the edge why
why would the like i'm just imagining
like the architect of that building just
being yeah this is gonna be hilarious
it's weird yeah it's good because like
they just wanted to make a fight between
kids because of course kids are gonna
[ __ ] fight each other and there was
like there was like there was like uh
there was that corridor and there was
two outside gates that also connected
that were pretty big so whenever it was
like snow or anything as well that would
turn into like the fighting zone yeah i
just remember the story of like going
back to the the teachers getting angry
outside of the school grounds did you
guys ever used to do like pe activities
outside of school yeah of course yeah
you'd go to them so like one of the ones
that we did uh quite often was because
our school was right next to a beach we
did a lot of like ocean kayaking
uh which was like really fun right like
you just like threw two or three boys at
a time get on with something
yeah oh yeah it was very dangerous um
but damn kayak i can't go yeah
i guess go kayaking you guys got to go
kayaking yeah what the [ __ ] what sailing
yeah we had sailing i learned how to
sail i'm sorry i'm so jealous
though i remember there was one story
for that there was one moment in
kayaking it's it's such a bad story but
uh there was like because we were on
manly beach and on one of the things and
one of the beaches uh because it's like
a bay basically so it's surrounded by
these cliffs and there's a lot of like
really like pristine like penthouses
that are like kind of overlooking the
bay if you like kind of look up at the
cliffs uh this is one time
where some we were just kayaking along
the bay
and then one of the boys was like oi
check it out
so i'm like what and we look up and
there's just like a chick standing like
in a bikini just like looking down at us
right
and uh you know she was a very
attractive lady
and we were you know we were like in
11th grade so we were like 17.
eating stuff like that yeah so basically
what about to commit
so one of the kids was like
sorry i know what he's gonna say so one
of the boys just starts going
tits out for the boys to sell for the
boys
tits out for the boys and that sounds
like the most australian [ __ ] yeah
and then a couple and then couple of the
other boys start joining along
and then before you know it
it's like there's like 15 kayaks like 30
boys in this bay just all going kicks
out for the boys to itself all the boys
the thunder joke
it was it was like a scene out of mad
max
it was [ __ ] cra and then of course
the girl
flashes everyone goes yeah
oh my god and the teacher and of course
and of course the teacher we had that
day was a female teacher she was like
what the [ __ ] are you boys doing
and we just like and we just bolt in our
kayaks just like get away from the
season we got absolutely rinsed
the most teenage australian boys story
i've like ever had only boys yeah yeah
this was this is when i was in the boys
i just remember that
[Music]
[Music]
they didn't let you do anything like
that no i mean like i i i wouldn't trust
a kid out in the sea i don't i'm
surprised i'm surprised that people did
we got to go to
um
little areas in wales that were like
kind of like camps for like three four
days
and um they were basically like they
would be like listen boys we gotta we
could do kayaking or you can do sailing
problem is we only got six sailboats and
we've got we've got that everyone else
can do kayaking like 30 kids i was like
well [ __ ] i to even though i didn't
really
like sailing i didn't know anything
about it i was like well that's the one
that has less i want to do that yeah
so i put my hand up to do it and somehow
i got chosen to do it i did sailing i
[ __ ] loved it it was amazing but they
gave us those like um you know boat
plastic like really cheap boat plastic
the one where they like knock it and it
sounds hollow yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's really coarse as well like it's
basically like a
a boat that was a shell of plastic with
a with a like uh what's it called as a
hull uh
what's the thing that goes through the
bottom
another rudder uh
sale
it goes in the bottom i have no idea i
don't remember
so you just have this slab of plastic
you put in to allow you to say all this
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we learned
how to sail and it was great and uh yeah
it was really good because like talking
about the mass the mess
i've never sailed before in my life
this was at the front and then it was
one way you turn it and then in the
bottom underneath the water you slide in
a thing
not the rudder
i'm sorry i'm not i don't know it's a
sailboat so you do you you didn't do the
direction with the the you did the
direction with the sail not that like
you'd pull on the
that right yeah sails you lean it's like
sorry it was really cool because like
you'd be doing that bad ass [ __ ] like
you'd be leaning yeah half the boat
would be out the water yeah yeah yeah
yeah
dude he was so [ __ ] like horizontal
just drifting
dude
maybe i don't know either way so and
then you would like you'd be taught like
okay let's say you flip your boat here's
how you jump out the boat jump on the
piece of plastic outside the boat push
it down jump back in the boat and get it
back yeah so [ __ ] cool i loved it so
much i got really good at it and then
the head guy was like you know what
every every every year or so there's a
kid who gets really good at sailing and
i let him try the the real boat and i'm
like oh [ __ ] really and then so he like
added this like really gross looking
shed in the water it was one of those
sheds that was like
there's no floor yeah it's just for the
boat yeah yeah he pulls out this massive
catamaran massive yeah bear in mind i've
been in this like one-person boat this
thing could easily fit like four six
people on it right he's like go take it
out for a spin
and i'm like i'm like i'm like
this looks [ __ ] scary what do you say
like the rich uncle owns a ferrari
the sword in the stone test yeah yeah
let's see if you can handle this one
right
so i started taking this thing out it's
going well i'm managing it it's a lot
harder you have to run you have to like
get across way more a lot more really
full body because you've got to really
like get under put your put your body
away you've got to like throw yourself
around on this thing to steer it it's
going well it's going well suddenly we
get a big gust of wind and i'm trying my
goddamn best to save this i'm trying my
best i get to the side i'm trying to
like i'm trying to unleash the mess so
that we can get some like we can get the
boat back down right unfortunately the
boat just keeps going it keeps going and
then it does it it gets sideways
completely from this point now this boat
is too heavy unlike the other boat right
my body weight could shift it back
my body weight can't do [ __ ] yeah and it
is literally like the sinking boat like
titanic it is just like i'm sitting on
the top of the boat like at the top
just slowly going down down
until it gets about the halfway point
where it won't sink anymore right
so i'm just sitting there and then he he
comes over disappointingly in like the
speedboat and he's like i see
he's like well he's like you want the
chocolate you're not the one
i see he's like well at least help me
tie this tie the rope around this part
and i'll turn it back over and then he
got on the boat and he was like i'll
show you how to drive it and i was like
i let him down i let him down he sailed
it back and then i was like a
disappointment and i was never allowed
to try it again
there was a [ __ ] i felt like that was
a look in hindsight that was ridiculous
i feel like that was a big step it's a
big jump alone as well with the camera
and you can normally have like two
people on it yeah yeah it's the big one
with the big net you know yeah yeah yeah
it's ridiculous it wasn't like a
full-sized massive one it was like a
smaller version but still it was like
i'm so jealous i never got to do that in
my school and we we live on a [ __ ] we
live in brighton you live in brighton
yeah yeah why white like
it was in a lake and a river so it's a
lot easier it was a really big lake
don't you wouldn't want to do that in
the ocean
that's dangerous
yeah i mean i don't think there's any
like big lakes near us so we didn't
really do any water sports i think the
most we did was we had like a we had
like a swimming pool a local swimming
pool
how far did you drive to get to this
lake uh two three hours
you drive two three hours just for this
that's like the entirety of wales that's
like that's like a
that's like a [ __ ] school trip for us
it was it was yeah it was like it was a
three-day weekend school trip oh you
made it sound like it was one afternoon
yeah you made it sound like oh yeah we
uh this is for this one lesson
three or four days three or four days oh
no because like the kayaking thing for
once was just like down there oh no no
no there's like it's like so there's
like areas in the i'm pretty sure it's
funded by the welsh government
like basically every welsh school gets
like a weekend there right so everyone
gets to have turns so these like they're
like really [ __ ] up that makes more
sense yeah there's like a you know it's
it's kind of like a thing you go it's
like hey try a bunch of different sports
try kayaking try uh canoeing try sailing
wall climbing like everything just
travel everything see what you like and
so it was really fun i'm glad i got to
do it i wish i kept up with sailing but
unfortunately
sailing is a
very luxury sport to be able to do yeah
yeah so not like oh yeah you can just go
sailing yeah yeah yeah unfortunately it
sucks really because i feel like there's
so many sports out there that i could
have fell in love with but the financial
stability of like i guess that's most
absolutely economical
that was like every sport ever for
everyone right i mean that's like that
was like me and skiing and snowboarding
that's why i never was able to get into
it because uh my family unfortunately
could never afford to go on a skiing or
snowboarding trip it's either not enough
money not enough space or both yeah well
i i'd love to i've been skiing and
snowboarding like the majority of my
life and i would love to earn a
snowboard or skis but it's an absolute
nightmare to deal with transporting it
yeah and taking it everywhere and i also
it's really expensive it is expensive
yeah i know that you can ship it from
hotel to like god you sound like you had
such like fun school trips like you you
went to like america for a school trip
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy to me well
that was that was insane that was like
the first year they did that yeah that
was really expensive as well i remember
i had to like beg my parents and they
were like
because our school wasn't that rich like
i think i think the richest thing that
our school did for the rugby team
because we like excelled in sports at
our school it was like the senior rugby
team was allowed to go to like play uh
rugby in europe for like oh wow wow yeah
but like that was only like the select
like maybe like you know top 20 people
who were like rugby i can't even
remember what we did for our school
trips
the rest of the time we just went to
like the local water silo yeah yeah
something boring i don't know if this is
just because like it's a really small
place but i imagine that when you're in
a city it probably feels like less
inclined to get you out of the city
whereas when you're in the countryside
there's nothing right so i feel like
they had way more
pressure to try and get you to do
something right especially because you
know in at least sport in wales like
sports is like a massive deal it's a
very important part of like the culture
and doing sports is seen as a very very
like you have to do it not doesn't
matter what you do just do sports like
yeah yeah you got to do so you know
there's a really big incentive for them
to make us go and do sports and go on
sports trips and do all this stuff
furthest we ever went in a school trip
or anything was like during like school
camps yeah but that we did every year
but and that was like maybe like you
know four or five hours away which in
the grander scheme of australia is not
far at all
but like yeah i don't i don't remember
like going on like school excursions
going further than like an hour away
yeah i mean i think the furthest i've
ever went for a school trip was like
france it's because every school trip
goes to france for like
you're in brighton that's right yeah
yeah exactly
you [ __ ] europeans got to go to other
countries that was not enough for us
other countries are like don't exist
it's like oh what's the closest country
uh papua new guinea how far away is that
uh like a three hour plane ride it's
like you're overall your own country is
like far away from your country we
couldn't we didn't even get to go to the
other states
like that's too far god god forbid we're
gonna be on a plane for an hour and a
half no of course not you probably had
better school facilities though than we
had we got to go on a trip and they were
like you just forget about the fact you
have to share a chair
i mean
no i mean even then it was like you know
like school like school camp for example
it was like yeah i guess you know
everyone got their own seat on the bus
or whatever but like that was the most
we got
[Music]
what privileged